but the reason for that is because we
just
launched finally the frenemies merged
hilo looking
show off your outfit show off your pants
those pants are so
and you make this [ __ ] look good man oh
oh yeah if you want to buy it it's that
teddy you won't it's at teddyfresh.com
slash frenemies you won't find it on the
website it's you have to go
slash for enemies right it's a little
secret so we'll see what happens with
this
abs convinced few of these guys are
convinced it's going to sell out but i
don't know if people still care
it's going to definitely sell out i i
have no doubt in my mind
i just bought something yeah but you
guys are just being sweet because you
know how stressed i've been about it
i'm not that sweet yeah you are stop it
maybe for you
are you hoping to resell it afterwards
oh yeah that's going straight on ebay
that's why i just didn't ask you guys
for one by the way you guys don't have
to buy [ __ ] you know we get i don't want
you guys to i don't want to make it
sound like you guys are like in grades
we usually hook you guys up with
whatever you want
yeah but if we're flipping it i mean
yeah if you're gonna flip it then then
i'm gonna fire you
if you're getting [ __ ] and flipping it
you know we got such a fantastic episode
today this is kind of an unprecedented
amazing episode
really yeah first of all we're sponsored
by expressvpn
epic today
they didn't pay for a round of applause
first of all happy friday so glad you
guys are here well first of all
no such thing as a coincidence guy is
calling in
is that a coincidence well clearly not
oh gabe is here
oh it is friday you know what that means
it's friday baby
where are you oh
his mic is not on whoo that's kind of
his
thing at this point there you go where
are you guys
i'm at the i'm at the lid i'll call it
the vegas eye baby [ __ ] baby [ __ ] yeah
oh you're on the field you're you're on
the ferris wheel at vegas
yep can you can you show us oh
baby [ __ ] baby
[ __ ] baby bro why why you got the best
life game yeah
i work hard baby [ __ ] you do work hard
man friday baby
happy friday bro is there work or school
tomorrow
no no work no school well i'm working
right now on the zoo
wow this is pleasure come on gabe we do
this for pleasure
all right gabe how much how are you
doing on cameo you're you're white claw
gabe on cameo are you crushing it there
is that why you're like living large
i'm crushing it baby yeah one of the top
earners
i saw you uh i saw you on the home page
oh yeah so how many cameos are you doing
in a day
how'd you do like maybe 20 to 40.
i'm so stoked for you ah i'm so happy
for your six
six white club game i mean you're such a
unique guy you're doing
you're doing beautiful things and um and
it's just such a joy to have you here on
friday
all right happy friday to you all you
can do some gambling out there
all right all right fantastic thank you
gabe
bye take care buddy enjoy the ride enjoy
the ferris wheel all right take care we
love you all right
happy friday all right happy friday baby
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
no school no work come on baby
[ __ ] baby no work hell no the weekend
[ __ ] all right all right
all right all right all right bye gabe
take care bye-bye
i love him he is doing so well
he's one of their top creators he's on
the home page of
cameo it's kind of been changing lives
that's kind of
i mean yeah for a guy like whiteclaw
gabe and he's got the perfect cameo
persona what the [ __ ] baby [ __ ] yeah and
like
he's one of their top creators man ah
that warms my heart bro that's
that's just awesome on the home page god
bless you god bless
him on the home page wow such a legend
i mean i don't what's he charged for a
cameo you see us oh good question
let's see because friday baby
whatever it is it's worth it i'm just
curious
he charges starting at fifty dollars
[Music]
with 20 a day holy [ __ ] no wonder he's
living large
yeah he responds in three hours wow
i think he bumped his price up because
he was just getting so much demand he
has a perfect five star
rating as well how could you go down
around three hours
yeah dude he's because he's a
professional on the call
he said he might sometimes get 40 a day
wow
wow at fifty dollars or per pop yeah
white club
that's two thousand dollars a day my
boy's crushing it
that's [ __ ] him yo he can make like a
you could become like a millionaire yeah
on cameo if he keeps it up
keep on that grind baby [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
no no wonder he's picking up bills he is
the man
god bless him you know we were goofing
on cameo at first but i'm starting to
see like
it's kind of really cool yeah i think
for some people it's like yeah offense
so fantastic yeah
uh real quick can we can we get a look
at those uh
nails sila oh you want to go ahead and
do some crazy nails you guys should
check it out
um ela did her nails i think this was
for in honor of theodore who loves
dinosaurs
work it work it get a little closer
there
we've got the triceratops we've got the
t-rex
we've got the bronchiosaurus
the velociraptor i love those man
mom is looking good enough to snack if i
was a t-rex i'd take a bite out of you
yeah so frenemies merch is up white club
gabe is here
we have so much to talk about man uh
we've we've got a great beautiful sketch
for you guys coming up a little bit
later too that we we shot wendy williams
news i mean
windy winds went off the rails bro you
know she got canceled like yesterday and
we had already had prepared a segment on
earth because she's with
wishing death on so many people and then
and then what is going on with her
i mean she did is that like part of her
stick
i feel like she just entered the
zeitgeist like in the past few years for
just being such a
i mean with peace and love i don't i
don't be rude but she's she's a strange
person
death to all of them and like who says
that i mean
you know there was this clip that
captivated us
you know yeah
should she suffer
all right clap if you think she should
suffer
she's talking about harvey weinstein's
wife i'm assuming or maybe ex-wife at
this point
i don't think he's getting any conjugal
visits dude his wife was like a
beautiful supermodel
should she suffer okay
you know it's like damn wendy like damn
some optics let's just do whimsy since
we're here
um should they suffer here's the one
where she goes
she's here my favorite is when she wish
to death on people i mean here
i would let them both drown too jen i'm
gonna tell you why girl you better stop
wishing death on people because you
almost dropped that
on your show a few weeks ago that's true
or a few months ago what did they say
something
no okay when she was had like a pass out
it's like girl
um that's like that was like two or
three years ago okay well i haven't
forgotten
wendy's one of the most wild
[ __ ] out there though
and i mean it uh first of all ben
affleck
gave me a five million dollar pink ring
we bought a beautiful
gone with the wind style in georgia i
put you in the bentley
and we did the video together we paraded
on the red carpet and you break off the
engagement and embarrass
me die
like they're okay with it on television
yeah i think it just went under the
radar for a minute die but then like
what the britney spears thing that
caught a lot of people off guard when
she was like
death to all of them i didn't know she'd
been wishing death to people for a while
to all of them i mean and to twist the
knife even further
in the ben affleck jennifer lopez thing
is that
it's not even like he's not the marion
kind he went off and married the other
jennifer
and they've got kids died
girl you need to join isis or something
whoa he needs to go move to like where's
isis stronghold
like syria syria yeah isn't this like a
daytime
family television show kind of thing not
definitely not family
i mean it is daytime yeah the kids are
at school presumably
okay all right because she likes stacks
she's stabbing and twisting
that girl ain't not right man
[Applause]
oh so this wishing death is a new
phenomenon it would
seem so so what's her problem
die well she's about she's got a plane
ticket to syria she's drinking
yeah i couldn't identify it if this uh
clip was before or after the britney
incident if it's after i would say that
she's just embracing the meme
she got so much [ __ ] because of the
britney thing that now she's like i'm
just going to wish death on everybody
i think this must i think it's before
well yeah and the last one that we're
going to show that one's definitely
after the britney episode so
here we go got this kind of
you had me speeding through numerous
traffic lights
doing gun play in a nightclub
you remember you had me do the purp walk
and spend a few hours in jail
die
her husband's watching this scared as
[ __ ] right now
and these wild women are all clapping
die
look at the death count die
die girl
relax
they're all clapping you know all right
people say that it's an
old clip by the way it's just yeah that
seems to be like we're there when they
first were together
i don't know because when they were
reuniting but yeah
people are saying it's a little bit of
an older clip so wait which one are we
talking about because there's the remix
and then there's the
the recent one that she's getting
actually canceled for the recent one
that one's after brittany
so this recent one is so [ __ ] wild i
don't know if you saw this
so i guess the story is what's this
guy's name he's a tick talker who
just let her explain it it's very yeah
she explains the whole thing
okay well right right i guess i'll just
let her take it away but she this she's
basically getting fully cancelled for
this you have to watch till the end
okay neither does one person in this
building
maybe sus does uh do you know who swaby
is clap clap
clap if you know who swaby is die
okay sauce
it's not mine it's not my cup of tea
that i got going on right now well he's
a tick tock star
he's got more followers than me
2.5 million
they don't like that on tick tock but on
instagram you have more followers
yeah [ __ ] that though right
well as my son kevin would say no one
uses instagram anymore
right so [ __ ] him on instagram and as
far as tick tock
i don't use that at all hell no
i don't know what that is i don't want
to be involved they don't want you
either way
so here he is
funny looking dude right douche right
get this about him he's 19. and he was
murdered
oh monday morning you believe my [ __ ]
you believe that [ __ ] time you
believe that set up
you believe how psychotic this woman is
what she's she's an absolute lunatic i
mean she's
just out of her mind what
yeah she spends she spends about a
minute and a half [ __ ] on him
and then goes yeah and he died it's
almost like she's like he deserved it
right
yeah why why would you even talk about
followers
yeah like having more photo and
instagram not being relevant and all
that
dancing on his grave oh my god this is
awesome right
wow well here's the reason why
wendy's not on tick tock that was so
shocking so she she yeah
so she's trending on twitter and
everywhere and people are like uh
this lady is not right in the head you
know
and so she's being fully canceled i mean
dude you can't it's like
between the wishing death on people the
mock stabbings and then tap dancing on
this dude's grave it's like girl
you got you got to be careful such a
bizarre way to say it
like yeah just the most odd i could
think of like she's angry
she said it like he deserved to die and
i'm glad he's dead
i mean that was kind of the vibe i got
from that whole speech
anyway here's what people on tick tock
think of wendy this was made by
tick talker t kyle enjoy this
[Music]
death death death to all of them
to all of them
[Music]
[Music]
to all of them what was that what was
that i wonder if it's in the clubs
it should be yeah that's awesome
yeah um so that's wendy she's out she's
out she's that is
out of control how's the friend
newsmerch doing by the way
felix can tell me quiz means merch
i thought for sure nobody's buying this
[ __ ] but let's see
um it's doing pretty good
i think i'm not sure because we got so
much it's hard to say
um it's so hot i'm so sorry i have to
take this off as much as i want to pump
the frenemies you know
here i'll do something like i'll put the
beanie here
oh the tumbler cup is sold out the
tumbler cup's gone
yeah oh [ __ ] okay
i guess people do the tumbler cup hey
all right let's get to the show you know
uh we're talking about
the title of course is ela's last
episode
um and i had and i hate to say it but
this is ela's last episode
for two weeks goddamn click click click
click click
what's happening it is technically true
i cannot believe you've done this but
you know you know
listen i had to find a way to tell you
guys he either's going to be gone for
two weeks
and also we're not doing after dark for
two weeks because i'm not doing the show
without ela that's
[ __ ] ridiculous thank you
i'm not going to sit here without you i
mean that's that's that's
kind of special yes you can't do it
without me
it is special you know it's just a
second episode of off the rails live and
nobody needs that it's like
off the rails alive i mean that's a
dangerous nomination
yeah off there i was live just be called
ethan's canceled
so do you want to talk about what you're
doing or no i want to i'm just
gonna you want to smoke it of family
members what are big pimps
you're gone for two weeks which is
interesting because i'm gonna be by
myself
what are you gonna do is the real
question lots of jerking off
no i'm kidding i'm just kidding okay
okay
i don't know i think i'm gonna it's me
it's me going with theodore if people
are not
following we're just going to spend some
time with family yeah
which is awesome i think it's been great
for you and theodore
it's going to be so weird for me to be
alone without theodore though i mean my
feeling is that you're going to be up
all night
every night how dare you
watching anime playing watching all the
enemies
blah blah
[Laughter]
talk about hamilton's soundtrack it's
embarrassing forget what you heard dan
there it is um
the truth is we're going to be working a
lot because even though there's going to
be no
friday after dark we have schemed our
way
we are starting a new channel
where we're going to be post you know
what what's
happening we're starting a new channel
the crew together is starting a new
channel where we're going to be reacting
to videos
or something we're figuring it out yeah
but um
obviously more info on that later but we
have a new project that we're going to
be going in
interesting going in on because you know
usually i have to rush home to take care
i did make ethan
make a promise to me and then was a
witness that
he promised we will not be canceled when
i'm gone no controversy i swear to god
i'm just gonna
just shut up zip it be cool just don't
[ __ ] this up
ethan every time ela goes to israel it's
like the israel curse
every time she leaves i [ __ ] it up and
ruin her trip
right and so like just be cool
don't say [ __ ] the mic scared me the
most
man i just i gotta do right this time i
just
and by the way when i'm by myself i'm
super vulnerable too like the last time
you went i was it was like i don't
remember what happened
oh i do i don't want to talk about it
but it was horrible it was awful for
everybody
so you guys all can watch me too yeah
okay ethan keep me on the road
shut up jeffy
man we have so much to get to today i
don't know how we're going to do it all
you want to see um oh the fans noticed
something
we on our last off the rails episode i
know if you saw it either
but the someone noticed something really
crazy about it which is
i can't believe somebody spotted this
somebody noticed that on the background
here i'll read the title
did anybody notice in the last episode
of off the rails they have subtly framed
signs of ryan cavanaugh allegedly
running a ponzi scheme
and a shitty trailer apps one star
review this is kind of subtle i would
expect it from david lynch this is
brilliant with your heart
thank you thank you i'm so okay actually
do you have those um
so glad you guys have those framed it
was very subtle
i actually didn't notice until i saw
this post yeah we put um
yeah i barely i barely noticed but like
for example this is the guy that's suing
us
ryan cavanaugh right he owns trailer
he's suing us for 50 million dollars
wow you believe that no i still don't
care
apparently the fight only pro only made
like 60 million
so basically he's saying we owe that
or half yeah we basically stole half of
all of their uh paper
by by watching it on our podcast right
watching thriller
my things flipped watching like 20
seconds or something of it
yeah so this is ryan cavanaugh he's the
owner of uh
co-owner of triller and uh well
according
variety wrote an article about him
according to his ex-partner he ran a
ponzi scheme his partner alleged that is
written by variety
variety yeah yeah they have they have a
lot of credibility variety that's a
that's a serious
paper well i mean as in terms of like
entertainment variety is probably
one of the most yeah right hollywood
reporter those are the two yeah that's
right that's so that's ryan
cavanaugh shout out to his ex-partner by
the way
oh such tremendous bravery yeah
i support him right also he bankrupted
his previous um company relativity media
which was like a
huge production house it was almost like
too big to fail you'd have to be a real
[ __ ] loser to bankruptcy yeah it's
incredible because they're very
very successful studio and yet somehow
he was uh able to run it into the ground
i guess or you know had some part of him
yeah
yeah i'm not sure oh no it's not alleged
he bankrupted it well right
i just don't know what we're gonna we'll
get into the details of that we have the
all the bankruptcy
um reports we're gonna get into that but
anyway this is ryan cavanaugh that was
subtly
hanging on the background i didn't even
notice that it was there
right that's really i mean it just
looked like a beautiful background i
didn't even
you know pay attention to that it's
aesthetics yeah and then i was like oh
what is that oh is that ryan cavanaugh
who was accused by zach's partner
running a ponzi scheme
like oh my god who put that there yeah
so he's actually trying to go public
with triller which is ironic because he
bankrupted his last
company i was like oh i don't know if i
want to invest in that
i might want to short it
so and then the other thing that was
hanging was my one star review of the
app trailer
nice yeah so that was just
people were wondering what it was so
somebody noticed that brilliantly
and um i just wanted to point so say
good job to
the faza for spotting that because
that was i mean you know good catch
you know yeah good eye
um dc okay you're gonna love that i'm
sorry you'll like this i
just looked up uh relativity media's
wikipedia page did you know
that um it was acquired by trigger
street productions
after it went out of um uh or went into
bankruptcy
which is owned by kevin spacey kevin
spacey bought his old [ __ ]
what the f relative what it says on
wikipedia
oh my god um
it looks like maybe the deal fell
through but um but yeah i mean these are
the people that are in the orbit of uh
ryan catholic
exactly exactly exact doesn't surprise
me at all by the way he looks so much
like
harvey weinstein it's crazy
what is that it was like a love sound
it's just a trunk
anyway um so moving on um
yeah okay you're gonna love this the
mayor of dc
tweeted out the photos
of an event thank you for joining us at
the palisades today
tell me which one of these images are
actually two of them really
[Music]
what doesn't fit he immediately erased
it
this is the mayor of washington or
of our capital of our state's capital
oh jesus he did a shot of uh
it's she she oh she yeah
it's freaky a shot of hentai mcdonald's
oh wendy's mcdonald's and kfc yeah yeah
and you know i could definitely beat off
to that so
that's pretty good wow wow
how do you suppose those got ner
in her tweets do you think like what
happened here
well you know with our uh with our
whatsapp group
uh every image that we ever share in
that group chat just kind of goes into
your gallery it always like pollutes my
gallery so i wonder if they're
she's just an epic memer if you're the
mayor
of dc and you're in a what are you
sending these kinds of memes to the
mayor of dc
yeah right somebody could be sending it
to her that's pretty wild though i like
i mean
[ __ ] yeah i mean i i don't think my mom
has images like that in her phone
[Music]
t-shirt is sold out oh my god are you
serious
yeah holy crap
so the cup is sold out and the shirt
yeah
whoa wow wow okay i guess people do want
this [ __ ]
by the way it's beautiful i mean it's
gorgeous like you guys are gonna be
really happy with that it came out like
amazing i mean you know it did it ela
made it
wow
um no such thing as a coincidence is
calling in
around oh wait isn't he bound to call in
already dan well we're coming up on the
break
in just a few minutes here and then
right after the break we will have him
calling so
very soon i'm about to introduce him in
this way ela watch this
your thoughts create you know tick-tock
yeah you still live a life that you
dress
when you visualize your dream so that's
our boy he's coming in
reality the grand rising william knight
i can't wait to talk i have so many
questions for him man
amazing oh and this is so exciting
this is actually you guys i gotta say
i am so i am so freaking
ugh no on a real note this this is huge
oh yes media monitors they do a survey
every quarter of people
and they ask what podcasts have you
listen been listening to
and this quarter h3 pod oh not this one
history podcast number 14 in the entire
[ __ ] world or united states but let's
be honest
i mean let's go
[Music]
let's go are you kidding me we're right
up there with the big boys
you know call me daddy just got bought
for 60 million dollars and they're only
four ahead of us and let me say that now
i will never sell to spotify
[Music]
don't care i'm already rich
i mean i want more money let's be honest
i just want to say uh
good job to all of you guys oh thank you
oh my god and yeah good job to you guys
thank you thank you you guys really are
thank you very much you guys no you guys
you're good
you guys no i mean it's such a team
effort here but it's just it's so
nice to see all the hard work we do and
we've been really working so hard and
trying to make
trying to make things happen and number
14 in the united states i mean that's
huge
we're above mark maron i'm sorry who
radio lab planet money i'm sorry conan
o'brien
all of those are so iconic yeah i mean
we're right below
like some of the biggest podcasts and
well they're all the biggest podcasts in
the world
one thing that bought studio 71 they
wrote that studio 71 produces our
podcast and i was like
whoo i mean their youtube network we do
this ourselves proudly from day one we
have
also we have nothing to do with them and
that's crazy we actually
really dislike them i think they're a
piece of [ __ ] i think they're just a
horrible
predatory very weird thing that happened
here
yeah [ __ ] studio 71 i don't know why we
emailed them we're like why did you put
that
but yeah i mean we've proudly from day
one done
everything ourselves yeah also like
all these big podcasts have publishers
and you know stu
but like they didn't even do [ __ ] like
why are they here get the [ __ ] out
get out
anyway so guys thank you for listening
that's super exciting
awesome man thank you thank you
and then just as just one more thing
here because we're kind of leading up to
um where's that image uh i kind of
wanted the image but
oh so so what do we see here uh this is
impulsive of the blue line
okay yeah right so impulsive
scroll down [ __ ]
impulsive by the way who's not even on
that list is currently ahead of our
pocket they had the number one subbed
podcast on youtube by 20 000.
yeah by 20 000. and i'm like i'm sorry
who like you're not even on that list
bro and he always goes oh we're the
number
one podcast uh in the world doesn't he
always say that at the beginning of his
i don't watch it so i don't know
i'm a [ __ ] but i'm like uh dude
we gotta i mean
foot soldiers this is this is just by
subscribers yeah just subs
all right but i can't accept that i mean
we got to do commit a war on
logan paul at this point let me tell you
about banana yeah come on
so anyway we oh god we have so much
stuff at the top of the show here
uh it is uh break time though all right
so we're going to throw it
we're actually well we're going to do
one ad here and then we're going to talk
to grand rising he's ready to go
okay fantastic so today's episode is
sponsored by expressvpn
watching netflix without using
expressvpn is like paying for a gym
membership
but only be able to use the treadmill
are you surprised that they're able to
like say this [ __ ] yeah netflix should
be like excuse me what the [ __ ]
they're like if you're using netflix
without faking where your geo location
is to get access to content you
shouldn't then you're a big [ __ ]
loser
netflix is like excuse me but hey that's
the truth
that's the power of expressvpn
expressvpn lets you change your online
location so you can control where you
want netflix to think you're located
they have almost 100 different server
locations so you can gain access to
thousands of new shows
this works with many other streaming
services too like bbc
iplayer youtube and more really youtube
i guess that's true yeah
is when it says blocked in your country
bye blocked no more
cut yeah uh i can say that canada
uk and japan netflix specifically i log
into
bomb content bro like crazy bomb
all kinds of new options
not only that but expressvpn has blazing
fast
speeds it can stream in hd with zero
buffering
it's compatible with all your devices
phones laptops media controllers smart
tvs and more
ca
[Music]
it's rock and roll encrypt your data
express vienna
expressvpn has all the added benefits of
encrypting your data so you can browse
the web securely
[Applause]
so be smart stop paying full price for
streaming services and only get access
to a fraction of their content
get your money's worth at expressvpn.com
h3
don't forget to use my link
[Music]
expressvpn.com
h3 to get an extra three months of
expressvpn for free
nice podcast sounds ethan audio audio
listeners are gonna love that one
all right grand rising
i uh have him on standby give me just a
moment to set it up
so we're sitting up here with william
knight
is his name and he's blown up i mean he
really has taken the world by storm
and the youtube comments i see his face
everywhere
cardi b switched her um profile
avatar photo too to william here let me
check cardi b on twitter and see if
she's still rocking it
yeah i believe so too let's see there he
is william knight yep this is cardi b's
tick tock
our twitter account
william can you hear me grand rising yes
i can hear you
william knight grand rising the man of
the hour
what how do you feel about being cardi
b's avatar is that a coincidence
[Applause]
i am very honored but i will always
remember
the first influencer to ever talk about
my tick tocks
was your show months ago really
always remember that yeah
there's no such thing as a coincidence i
knew we were early on that on that train
oh my god i didn't know we were the
first though yeah i never i can never
tell
the first time wow
okay i'm not gonna ride it did freak me
out oh well
well you freaked us out too with your
with the air tick tock so the feeling so
there is no such thing as coincidence
and we've always been energetically
aligned
let me ask you uh first of all i'm so
honored to have done that because you
are this phenomenal character
you're taking the world by storm cardi b
has your logo
face says their avatar all the youtube
comments like 50
of them are your face by the way now too
do you know that
i didn't know that now yeah check the
comments there's a lot of people that
started doing
following cardi b's uh uh
yeah her lead so what is your what is
your story william knight of the grand
rising oh you have an app i'm just say
that grand raising app let's [ __ ] go
what's your story dude yeah so i have
aligned with my purpose in life after
years of
being in the matrix and i am
wanting to create services and messages
to really wake people up to this
simulation that we live in
i want people to know that they really
can't control their lives with just
their thoughts
what's this glove you're wearing can i
get a look at this is it like a full
thing or does it just go to the
elbow egg what's my elbow oh okay
nice is it just it's like a fashion
thing or to keep your hand warm
yeah i just love my all black i'm really
into
my fashion that it's it's a pastor's
line
so so do you believe that yeah oh
definitely
look bro there's a lot of a lot of
positive comments uh
uh of people saying he's uh so good
looking in the comments right now do you
get that a lot
okay here what do we live in the matrix
for real is that a real thing
i do believe of course yeah
society was built in a very strategic
manner is to get people to consume
products consume chemicals consume
messages and it's it's out there there's
a lot of declassified documents
from the cia that has confirmed a lot of
the things in a lot of the propaganda
that they've done
to control the masses it's out there oh
it is okay
what kind of chemicals are we consuming
i haven't heard that one
um i i really want to focus on the
chemicals we can consume
to help enlighten our ascension help
decalcify the pineal gland
so i'm all about raising the vibration
you can do that with meditation
affirmations with your diet there's so
many ways
to cleanse the body from all the things
that we
consume especially americans it's not
common our diet is not common in other
countries there's a lot of products that
are
banned in other countries that we eat on
a daily basis so
what should we be avoiding so what what
should we avoid eating that's
[ __ ] up our vibrations most people
already know it's
um all the processed food right all of
the genetically modified
vegetables the um when it comes to
animal products there's a huge debate on
whether animal products are good for you
i i stand with
know where the animal is coming from
know how the energy of the animal is if
it's in a factory farm it's
depressed it's a whole life in a cage
and you're eating that energy
oh you're going to get that same energy
so
get grass fed get organic get fresh meat
in other countries they eat their meat
fresh
ours is frozen and processed got it so
it's all about the energies
so theoretically if i eat like a happy
person is that good energy
if you're around a happy person
definitely okay person that you
are in communication with once you watch
online
okay you match their vibration okay
um the girl in the woods you scared was
that a real video
yes that was a movement and i was very
nervous to post that video
because of that reaction that day i was
didn't have time to re-record and i was
in a rush to meet a friend
so i just held on to that for a few
weeks and then i eventually
i eventually decided to post it for the
message i didn't expect it to get a
big humor reaction and become a meme so
that was probably the biggest
shock i've had on my channel because of
all the other videos
wow would you call that a coincidence or
no
no it wasn't it took me a few days to
realize that it wasn't a coincidence i
was
freaked out with how viral it was going
it took me a few days to really just
accept it
and realize that it was all part of the
plan because
a lot of people there was a big debate
yeah around
if you're some kind of mastermind that
like the plan
land this whole thing with the job
because it just it just was work it just
came together like so
the timing of it was unbelievable
there's a lot of conspiracies
people think i use a green screen people
oh wow
there's a lot of rumors about my content
but i really am serious with my message
um i do
love to dress this way um i do add a
filter on my eyes
just because i um i i like to just
enhance certain things about myself
but i really am being serious and i
really do have a message
so um was this woman just a random
pastor buyer and
and uh she moved on you continued the
video
and you you have no connection with her
you never talked to her we don't know
who she is yeah people
are trying to figure out the validity
but i want people i want people to
really know
when it comes to everything in life
like your reality none of this is real
these are all atoms moving if you zoom
in on any object
in your environment right now you'll get
atoms moving and vibrating at a certain
frequency
that's we're just perceiving this like a
dream this is a joint
hallucination that we're all having
together like
none of this is real that's why the
phrase wake up
is um very big there's a grand awakening
happening right now
with reality
that's amazing that was coincidental
dude oh my goodness
so um when you were debating if to post
this video or not
were you afraid of like
of like how it would be perceived and
then ultimately you said this
this turned out good except for the girl
being scared this is a good video
let's put it up yeah i was nervous
because i do
um i thought people would just assume it
was fake because i was advertising
my new meditation in my app and so i
immediately
just had it in my phone for weeks i
didn't it kind of worked out for you
it was a it was a ad for the app the
ground rising app
and it ended up being your most viral
video it was an ad for a
it was an ad for a new meditation that i
was experimenting with now announcing
that meditation
that's one reason why i kept going after
the screen was i wanted to
finish my message and get that out
and i didn't have time to stop and
re-record
were you were you confused by her scream
like why did she scream at you
react like that
in the moment i was kind of just in the
zone i do a lot of my
videos where i am just trying to process
i like
kind of channel a message that's a lot
of times why i don't end up blinking
and so um i didn't really process what
had happened until afterwards
[Laughter]
but you ever wonder like why is she
screaming at me like she was frightened
by you i don't know what what did you do
that frightened her so much yeah i wish
i was i wish i had time to check up on
her by time
yeah she's fine she's gone she's fine
oh it's one of my favorite videos of the
year
so tell me about this app what's this
app you're working on
so i released a iphone app that sends
your phone
positive affirmations throughout the day
so it's
teaching you the idea that your thoughts
really create
your reality the only issue with your
thoughts is
remind being reminded to focus on your
goal one thing to have a goal
but i wanted a tool i made it for myself
originally
i wanted something that was going to
remind me throughout the day that wasn't
just a sticky note in the bathroom
about what my goal was and so it really
was something uh for myself
um and then i was i thought obviously i
could share this with the world and then
it's
it's kind of become a bigger thing and a
bigger
goal of mine to help other people now
are you an
alien william
and uh the android app also comes out
comes out in august are you a merman
no i am not an aquafan not in this
lifetime oh not in this lifetime
i want to ask you one last question does
the media have an agenda
i thought you might have an insight on
that
ever since my platform has increased
i've been swaying away from certain
topics trying my best to
and i've actually have been getting
tick-tock
notifications where they were removing a
lot of my previous videos
um people have been sending me a lot of
my old videos
asking me to re-upload but i just i'm
just very cautious about what i talked
about now oh oh okay we don't want to we
don't want to talk about the media's
agenda because
right that makes sense well william i
wish you all the best with um
the grand rising app and i can
i can tell now that we are energetically
aligned after all
i mean we really truly are right i mean
from
from 1 000 and you'll be seeing a lot
more of
my oh i'm sure i don't know that i can
see more of your face i see your face
literally everywhere i started thinking
in my sleep
if i see it anymore would you be me
staring at myself in the mirror and i
just look like you
um is there any such thing as a
coincidence
that's one of my most common commonly
asked questions
and the answer is yes and no oh so your
beliefs really dictate
how your life will turn out so if you
believe in coincidences
the universe will give you a life full
of coincidences but if you believe that
there's no such thing as a coincidence
everything is in your control there's no
such thing as chance
then the universe will prove that to be
correct
so that's so the words of the phrase
believe i have control
okay so when you say there's no such
thing as a question
that's not entirely true
i'm trying to wake people up to the idea
that there
really is no such thing as equipment
there really is
a meaning for all of it but a lot of
people are
thinking that life is just chance and so
they're living that life
and for certain people they'll continue
to have that life
for me it wasn't an option um there were
a lot of things happening that were
blowing my mind that i felt i was going
crazy
and i wanted to kind of just throw them
off as coincidences because
i feel like there's something waking me
up that
wouldn't let me go back to the matrix
that's is that the grand rising
or the grand awakening or something
yeah definitely there is a a grand
rising a mass waiting for
a lot of people but not everyone will
will get the ascension well bro i i
think you're amazing i think what you're
doing is awesome
i the app sounds phenomenal it sounds
like a really positive thing
and um i'm going to keep watching your
videos i can't get enough of them so
as far as coin as far as coinance
coincidences go i'm just going to go
ahead and say there is no such thing i'm
with you
yeah all right dude stay energetically
let's stay energetically aligned all
right
oh we definitely will thank you guys so
much for having me william nice thank
you brandon rising
on tick tock grand rising app
you're going to be doing great things it
talks instagram i'm just joined twitter
and it's going to be a a fun ride so i'm
rooting for you
and i we're going to be seeing great
things from william knight so thank you
so much buddy take care
and we will talk again all right bye
the grand rising we love that william
so i i'm kind of shocked because he got
because
when i asked him if there's no such
thing as coincidence i just expected a
straight up
no but the man has um
what a twist he has thoughts about
things yeah for sure
i kind of i'm i kind of wanted to crack
him on some of the
some of the really i know he has
interesting thoughts about stuff
yeah i thought you want to ask him if he
was a mermaid i did he said no oh i ran
to the bathroom sorry
or aquiferian he calls it right oh right
yeah oh why didn't we think of that
aquafarian yeah he corrected me i said
mermaid and he says
i'm sorry i missed that i had to run to
the restroom
but he's like he's being very calculated
because he's in the me and i understand
that but i really want to
know what i want to know what he thinks
about like the me
you know mm-hmm the reptilians
interesting maybe once he gets more
comfortable on the internet and he knows
that
people aren't coming from anyway what a
treat huh yeah
there's no such thing as a coincidence
man do you believe him or is he still
putting it on about that
video being real no i believe it i
believe that's exactly what it is
that's too good i can't believe it it's
definitely real
that's the video of the year already
yeah i mean he's recording in a public
space of course there's gonna be joggers
and people and uh
yeah but he says he didn't have time to
re-record it how's that possible it's
just like a 10
second video it was it was more in depth
than that
maybe it was maybe like at least like 30
seconds i guess he nailed it you know
and he's like [ __ ] it
can you imagine if he erased that one
like what a missed opportunity that
there is no such thing as a coincidence
man
fascinating wake up how's the frame he's
doing people are buying it so
there's another update the long sleeve
is sold out now wow
[Applause]
no we're actually going to deliver this
don't play the big connect sound
not a scam let me see the numbers
because i know like the
hoodie we got a frick load of um
takes a minute let's um
we can come back to that okay yeah
so anyway um god there's so much stuff
to get to
uh here's walmart on the fourth of july
you know
we live in truly the most bizarre
country in the world
i really don't know what else to say um
and people loved this too they thought
they people thought this was so cool
i thought this was like a dystopian
nightmare man
look at this very patriotic scene in
texas walmart someone started singing
the national anthem and everybody joined
in
oh god quiet walmart
[Music]
ain't nothing more american than walmart
[Music]
get grab a mountain dew box there ain't
nothing american about that
[Music]
there's a bunch of people with diabetes
who can't pay for insulin singing
the american anthem and walmart
come on grab that mountain dew now i
can't afford
i cannot afford um insulin but i sure
can't afford this 12-pack of mountain
dew
that's 50 off today
you're telling me it's like so american
would this happen in any other country
oh no i saw there was a reply to this
that stuck with me
where somebody just said um you know
people in north korea
are so brainwashed that they'll just
spontaneously break out into the korean
north korean national anthem in public
oh my god and uh
listen just to be clear i love america
me too but this is just funny but this
is too much
i cannot afford insulin um
i cannot afford insulin boy but i did
walmart song
but i can get two mountain dew 12 packs
for 50
for 250. the doctor says they're taking
my leg off next week
pass me that mountain dew okay i'll take
a diet mountain dew
can we watch the walmart song it's
seriously one of my favorite videos
we are walmart of all time oh yeah for
sure
everything everyone this is like the
worst of america i don't know it's
because it's like
walmart is this mega corporation that
pays their employees so little
that they're actually on public
assistance their
employees are so poorly supported
that they have [ __ ] food stamps that
they use guess where
at walmart how do you know that that's
crazy
this is a well-known thing about walmart
they literally cost the american
government
so much money and public assistance
because they don't pay their employees
enough
and they like systematically cut their
hours so they don't have to give them
benefits
oh god
[Applause]
everyday low prices come on dad get down
here now
they pay you know it's ironic they pay
them so little money
that the only place they can afford to
shop is walmart
you got them sucking that funnel now
boys hold on get them seeing an american
flag
make them think this is the best country
in the world
you know walmart of all places
is the [ __ ] ugliest side of america
golly they putting out mom and pop
stores
all around the country and then giving
worse shittier jobs
and getting people stuck in poverty they
are a blight on society
but i will tell you it's the only place
i can get a 12 pack of mountain dew
for 1.99
but doctor says i'm going to lose both
my legs
but this mountain dew is way too good of
a price
you know what i learned that it's so
wild uh recently
that um you can buy jordans on walmart
oh like exclusive jordans yeah because
they have like that aftermarket [ __ ] now
that like everybody's doing these after
market
uh like community places to sell [ __ ] i
don't know why i thought that was so
funny
yeah that is weird so um before we watch
we are we are walmart
here is the son of ronald reagan
the literal son of rogen reagan reagan
what did i say rogan reagan
oh ronnie reagan out here
so this is ronald reagan's son on
newsmax talking about what a beautiful
video this is listen to this
so who got chills show of hands from
here 98 year old world war ii
i got chill like diarrhea chills you
know when you have a mask like a really
sometimes you get chills when you have a
really bad diarrhea no you don't know
what i'm talking about yellow
okay i i know it's really thank you
dan's looking at me like i'm crazy i
don't know i'm looking at him
i know that [ __ ] chills thank you
veteran play
national anth them on our harmonica
hands up i i think we all got our hands
up here um
but you know it was amazing michael when
you think about you know the two
different countries we kind of live in
where you have these elite athletes that
are
in this world of privilege and you see
just regular old folks in walmart some
place in town i can't [ __ ] get over
this is so racist they go they go this
is a world of elite athletes black
people
this is a world of elite athletes and
good old folks in walmart
these are the only two types of people
in the world
not billionaires how about about the
people that own walmart that are
literally pillaging
following what are we watching okay
right i'm getting ahead of myself let me
just play it you know i think that
really represents two different
feelings about this country we have
right now you have these elite who get
all the attention
but then i think in middle america folks
still really love this country
all people really do love this country
and it was shown there at that walmart
we need more walmarts in this country
especially after this absolutely you
believe this guy's sipping for walmart
fourth weekend and all the shootings and
all the killings that took place
we need more walmarts and that's what
america needs to get back to
we've lost our moral compass and we need
to find that world
as my father said when we cease to be
one nation under god we become a nation
gone under
and right now this is my first
this guy says the moral compass of
america is planted in walmart
he also seemed to imply that uh there
would be less mass shootings if there
were
more walmarts you know what we need out
here
uh no not at all i think there'd be more
because it's just poverty i mean poverty
is the
is a plight on society it creates more
crime it creates more um
um everything poverty makes everything
worse
i think we need a warm poverty you know
what we need down here
is more walmart and at 12 o'clock now
come on everybody's got to stop and sing
the national anthem
or you get hung back down back
that's not if you don't sing that's not
american we'll take you back
and lasso you yeah
don't don't forget to grab
10 bags of doritos cool ranch
it's only 99 cents for 10 bags hey
come on out don't knock on cool ranch
doritos
hold on but what else should i say i
don't know
those are bomb though i mean i like
doritos too i mean i also like
i like the mountain dew i mean you know
what the [ __ ] yeah
don't chill dan yeah you're simping for
walmart now you're ready to do that
no but i'm sipping for some doritos or
at least the cool
i'm not really about the nacho cheese
ones are
kind of gross you can dress your whole
family for two dollars
at walmart come on down to walmart you
can dress your whole family
for 10 cents you want the we are we are
in walmart
yes we're getting kind of sidetracked
but that's okay so here is
a manager of walmart hyping up his
i think this was like a black friday
these people now these people are big it
makes so little money they're probably
on [ __ ] food stamps okay
the minute i make any of you guys do any
of this you can fire you can leave you
can leave
you can leave just quit on the spot
[Music]
[Applause]
walmart under god one nation
god is the greatest
oh yeah i love it
get it one more time now
all right guys let's get out there and
earn our eight dollars an hour
dan i wish you loved your job as much as
this guy maybe you
inspire some [ __ ] morale around here
you want me to like lead that chant
before you guys get here
yes morning to kind of get everybody
hyped up get everyone awake man okay
look at the energy level's higher i'll
consider it guarantee i pay
you at least 10 times what this guy
makes okay
[Laughter]
someone said we did this when i worked
there
no seriously oh bro something happens in
more than one story i have to know if
you're serious
i wouldn't be surprised i feel like
that's kind of like that might be a
company-wide initiative
wait what all walmart
and sam's club employees have to do this
stupid chant
at every meeting are you guys serious
are you just
pranking us right now i think they're
real i think this is real you know it's
like
these these low paying demeaning jobs
are bad enough but they
[ __ ] humiliate you by making you
participate in this [ __ ]
like you can't have your dignity this
this is what this is not to inspire you
this is to strip your dignity as a human
being
to participate in this i'm
shocked you know what i'm saying anyway
enough with the social uh
you yeah they're not here to get [ __ ]
preach too i'm saying i don't know if
it's specifically this but there's
something called the walmart
cheer which appears to be uh widespread
okay wait let me google this because now
you know it's the walmart chair
we will we will cut your hours so you
don't get benefits
we will we will pay you not enough money
to ever crawl your way out of that and
have to use public assistance
here's a compilation of the walmart
cheer apparently
wait how can they just rip off that song
they would need to license
yo don't pay enough money for this
is it like the managers get to make
their own cheer yeah maybe they all have
they just this one i like better we
gotta dance with this one
yeah when i'm reading it's kind of wild
though what are they doing a docido or
some [ __ ]
they rehearsing this bro what
this is not acceptable this this is
north korea
and if you don't there's not oh brother
you cannot [ __ ] pay me to do this
i don't know there's just something so
wrong about this
you can get 10 gallons of ice cream for
188
they go the mom and pop the bomb and pop
store
across the street sells it for two
dollars so we're gonna sell it for 188
i'm gonna come what the [ __ ] yo this is
a lot of rehearsing
this one's a pretty elaborate yeah
yeah i don't think that they're all like
this
yeah it's a very uh yeah it is kind of
like a marching band did they say form a
union
oh [ __ ] they're about to all get fired
wait hold on look at this
wait what the [ __ ] is that it's your
right to form a union i don't know where
you're
mark i don't know what you're watching
so this game
i think all those people got uh burned
alive in the furnace back
rumor has it if you mentioned union and
walmart they just dropped there's like
a floor there's a trap door under you
they turn off
yeah uh that almost certainly was not a
uh sanctioned
thing that you just pulled up all right
let's move on eh
yes all right yeah
oh here dude there's so much stuff here
i'm sorry but like dude eli just feast
your eyes on this
we made such a good sketch today i want
to get to it but like just watch this
here just feast your eyes on this 18
second masterpiece
what
pretty amazing stuff pretty amazing i
mean
it's pretty great these boomers are
really good on tick tock man
like i wish i could make something this
interesting
the sound effects you could totally see
this on adult swim like for sure
midnight just adult swim boom yeah
[Music]
that's it let's move it on there's way
too much stuff at the top of our show
here i feel like every
everything we're watching today is
proving um williams
there's no such thing as a conspiracy
over in the matrix yeah
right
there's no such thing as a coincidence
the fact that you can buy 12 mountain
dews at walmart for 175
means there's no such thing as a
coincidence
the fact the fact that insulin costs 10
000 times more than a 12 pack of
mountain dew
means there's no such thing as a
coincidence there's no such thing as the
coincidence
you know zach someone say that oh i
forgot to ask him about the curse
um zach you have evidence that the curse
is real you got into a car accident
i did i have a hard [ __ ] evidence
that this [ __ ] [ __ ] is real because
wait when did the accident happen yeah
uh yesterday
so zach got into a car it doesn't look
that serious what happened here
just a little bump there yeah so yeah i
got um i was making a protected green
left turn wait this is your car right
yeah where's the top punch
it's over the right wheel well this
yeah it's dented it looks like a
reflection
yeah it's dented is there any damage i'm
laughing what a tragedy when he came in
he goes i kind of [ __ ] actually well
because i take care of my
dad he goes i care about my car yeah i
don't know
where is it no you get it fixed already
it's dented
it is i don't see any damage because
this is just a reflection i think if we
just got one of those little suction
things those
well no i gotta take it to another the
other guy's car got a nice little yeah
you can see who hit who though
like he he totally well [ __ ] him
yeah your car though so zach videoed
this guy he
panicked it's pretty awesome he uh he
was flipping and i tried to remain calm
because you know
zach i've never heard zach talk so sweet
and soft
because i wanted i wanted to show so bad
like it pissed him off tremendous that i
wasn't reacting
so basically you're we blurred his face
so don't worry about it uh so your
theory is that we've been [ __ ] with
the
cleveland cleyden's klein water yeah
we we we've been poking the bees too
much okay ethan klein
we've been poking the bees too much and
yeah i was making a protected green
left-hand turn and this [ __ ]
comes into my lane as he was making a
right and
[ __ ] hit me and he totally denies
that
so you guys so you pull you both pulled
over right side right and
this is you confronting him right he
just came out of his car raging
okay here you go eel is pretty good i
gotta say i wasn't
listening how soft jet that's gentle sir
look what you did in my car
you sound you know who you sound like
mobility married
i i had the exact same thing
you almost hit me he he was just so
raging i mean he
at one point he came super close to me
and you know took
everything in my power he was kind of
thinking about hitting you he wouldn't
have a chance again you were way bigger
than he was oh he was a little short
little [ __ ]
and
can you play some uh mobility mary sound
bites on yourself
sir you almost hit me listen
sir look what you did in my car
you sir
you're trying to provoke him aren't you
no i was trying to remain calm
like honestly like i heard you hit
michael i just i just wanted to get the
[ __ ] out of there because i
i was tired and i just wanted to get the
[ __ ] home
and i didn't want to [ __ ] deal with
this [ __ ] were you mad i was
[ __ ] livid right because you sound so
like
well i wasn't about to i didn't want to
push myself i needed to calm myself down
you did good i'm proud
of you here listen to this please calm
down you didn't look sir
what i was looking i was waiting for
this woman and i was turning in this
lane
you must have come in this lane i didn't
go in that way oh my god
let me see your insurance card like he's
such a dick are you going to see mine
dude you were playing him so hard you
went into me
i was being paid please come back i am
calm but you hit me
okay let me calm and you did well let me
see your insurance card that made him
even more mad
let me see your id you hit me i didn't
go in that lane
dude [ __ ] how the [ __ ] did i get
if i'm in this lane this guy sounds like
how did i hear
you i'm in this way you were in my lane
you made
were you why then why are you getting so
angry which way did you come from
turning left you didn't see you were
turning left exactly you're supposed to
it was a green
it was a green arrow no
yes did you not see that i was waiting
for that woman to cross and it just
there was no woman it did not go red it
was green for me i had a protective
green yeah you could but if he had green
you you have to yield on a green light
no no it was a protected green oh you
had a green arrow yeah yeah which means
you have the right-of-way exactly he had
a green light which means you have to
yield i don't think he even had a green
light no he didn't know
he he was arrow then he was his was red
yeah
he kind of so he must have been in the
intersection already
he was turning he was turning right he
turned right on a red
yeah but there's two lanes and he came
into my i see yeah oh he's running right
on a red but yeah he needs to yield for
you
if you look at the damage it's i mean
it's the front of that dude's car the
side of
zack's car it's obviously a great video
such a good rage video yeah
sir you hit me oh my god
dude i was waiting for her what are you
gonna do you're gonna hit me
no you're lying
you're not supposed to make a turn okay
can i see can i see your driver's
license do you admit you were in this
lane
i'm not admitting anything you weren't
there you go gotcha no you're the one
you literally said i'm not admitting
anything
goddamn you're paying up buddy he got
you good zach
[ __ ] this guy steve is such a [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ]
so this is so you think this is a
manifestation of clyden's klein water
it's it's facts and he was
you know he was probably listening to it
yeah he
[ __ ] was that's [ __ ] i mean
because you hit me and i think you hit
me
you hit me yo maddie gets this piece of
[ __ ]
your id well where's yours it's right
here
what kind of driver's license is that
that's the real idea
this guy's unreal nazi it's a valid
driver's license
is that you don't even look like you
it don't look like you this guy is
unreal
[Music]
wait i i wanted to play cleared into
clean water please don't
plea please hold on this is too good
hang on
because it's called client one [ __ ] i'm
in this place
you're not supposed to make it this is
the purse curse
you're going to get a question there you
go
you're the one that's angry someone's
got a [ __ ] hitting me in the head oh
that's failing
come back yours i love that he questions
that you have a fake idea that's pretty
amazing
the curse got out of the if we get
claimed will you believe in the curse
yeah we're gonna get [ __ ] claim now
i'll snip it out and then zach will be
happy anyways this guy was a real
[ __ ] [ __ ]
and um yeah [ __ ] him yeah that was
pretty awesome he was like this isn't he
doesn't even
look like you this isn't a real idea
yeah like oh you've definitely crashed
into zach if you're
nitpicking that much oh yeah you can see
how angry he was getting without talking
to you
yeah i was just over your ordering lunch
i'm like what am i
my stomach is like making noises
oh really well so is mine is that
i actually have a salad in the fridge
okay let me you can order
let's talk about twitch gambling because
this leads into the sketch which is
really
all i care about today
okay this is a crazy story last week we
talked about um
the crypto scheme going on that was two
days ago
it wasn't last week oh i meant a few
days implies misspoke
but what's actually i think what's going
on on twitch is even worse is that a lot
of people
are being paid millions of dollars to
gamble
yeah i had no idea me neither that is so
crazy
i was hanging i was just i learned this
from a a big twitch person i was hanging
with recently
and they were telling me about all about
this yeah what
yeah i'm sorry well you know i have a
lot of friends who do twitch
so um the thing is
like and then the thing is these guys
are exposing themselves by
they like open a dm for example like
aidan ross this
[ __ ] um look at this
he accidentally opened while he was
streaming
his contract oh and so that's how we
figured out kind of like
like this guy told me how much people
are getting paid and like
but like here you can see for example
adam ross sees this huge streamer he
gambles all the time
well maybe not anymore right didn't he
just get banned yeah he got like
suspended for a way i don't think he got
back oh no no
he said it was a permanent man yeah but
he was lying just for
i think he's he doesn't know it's
permanent but he probably got banned for
a week or something gotcha
anyway he's one of the biggest ones and
all of his fans are kids for sure
and he's gambling all day and he uses a
vpn
he lives in l.a he which is illegal to
gamble
huh he uses a vpn to connect to the
gambling site because you can't connect
legally yeah through california
he gambles on twitch he's paid millions
of dollars to do it by the company
but how is it okay because twitch knows
he's here
i mean i guess i guess twitch is like
hey it's not our job to regulate
we're only concerned about uh hot tub
streamers over here
that's that's our primary concern uh
illegal gambling with children that's no
problem that's fine
the crazy thing is that you know and and
one example of what could happen is
if you look at the country of lithuania
was it or
or slovakia oh
were they banned so someone someone in
slovakia was doing this illegal gambling
yeah and now they're starting to ban
twitch for everybody in slovakia because
they're legally gambling there i mean
it's a gateway to gambling
yeah especially for underage kids right
i mean we heard the effect of lovehead
when he was gambling on cs go wild which
faze banks owns
we found out for sure that phase banks
owns that or owned
well at least he claimed to at one point
yeah i don't know yeah he owns it yeah
right
what are we going to split hairs phase
banks goes yeah i made i made things go
wild
right he said that and then later i
don't know whatever
you know obviously he was involved but
anyway like
um so here's aiden ross
and this guy doesn't give a [ __ ] this is
the guy who's like yeah i've i promoted
milf coin
i hope none of you guys bought it
because that [ __ ] is such a scam
but anyway here he is on stream and oh
what's this
this conversation popped up for one
split second
so here he is talking with one of the a
dual bits i guess
is one of these gambling sites he said
they offered me a back they said i
offered you
two million dollars per month lowell wow
two million per
month oh my god imagine how much money
they're actually making
for that to be worth it what i get this
he says he says no you offered me 1.4
and didn't cover other expenses but
rubit
i guess is covering expenses plus we get
referral code money
we are getting more sorry bro
oh maybe we can work again soon you kept
all of your referral code money as a
group lola for 1.6
so this guy's like i basically with
everything i'm offering you it's close
to two million
and he's saying i got a better offer so
they're negotiating
a multi-million dollar deal
discord dms wow because the whole thing
is super shady so
it's all super shady it's all
unregulated
and you know what unregulated means
unregulated means
that these websites could be controlling
the outcome
right it means they could be go like the
gambling side you mean
yeah if it's unregulated they could do
[ __ ] anything they want
they could be giving him fake money to
gamble with
right they could be controlling the
outcome of his bets to make it look like
he's getting
big jackpots in reality you guys got
scammed so how is this
happening here well it's kind of just
it's one of these things
where it's just happening there's a
shitload of money
and it just happens i mean twitch
doesn't have a policy apparently you can
gamble on twitch
so it's just this thing i think all
these sites paying this crazy amount of
money are all super shady
the content creators who are taking the
money have absolutely no [ __ ] ethical
uh awareness and and and it's just a
bunch of shitty people doing shitty
things but it's going to catch up
just like this crypto thing is blowing
up because these people are all
this is straight up illegal
um here it says legal gambling is
allowed on twitch
with site sporting official sections for
slots and poker
so they even have an official section
for slots in poker
but it's very popular people like
watching here's some clips for example
this guy rosh stein one
apparently he won 2.5 million dollars
on stream now again i if this is an
unregulated site
i'm doubting any of these um
jackpots because they could just make it
happen to get people
to want to bet right you can see he's
got his like deposit code
his promo code he's pushing everyone to
sign up i mean these are kids let's be
honest
here look because i've been actually
in the food party for seven dollars soon
without
going down yeah exactly and as you know
if you if you play a slot machine for
seven hours you win every time
people don't win in slot machines people
don't win in gambling period ever
end yet somehow these guys are winning
millions of dollars
look hilo 2.5 million dollars yeah
right
[Applause]
2.5 million no way
show your screen
[Music]
oh my god i see this
[Music]
long
you know that's a really good question
and
and what was the hell yeah from that was
from dream when he cheated on his
uh right go
[Laughter]
same energy for sure i'd like to
i'd like to say i i don't know hilo
but there's something about the live
component that's just really hard to
regulate in real time but i'm pretty
sure
youtube is youtube is so much smarter
than twitch you cannot gamble
you cannot show yourself gambling on
youtube you know why
because they're not crazy they say this
is not legal
in most places and we can't control from
where you're watching this from
necessarily or maybe i'm wrong can you
find gambling on youtube i don't know
i don't think you can promote it like
they're doing i'm saying that the policy
is not very clear but recently they did
a lot of banning no actually i'm sorry
this back 2019 a lot of banning on uh
gambling channels someone said that this
guy does
gamble on regular regulated sites
and he's down a lot and is transparent
about his losses
okay i don't know but i don't think his
losses matter when he's being paid two
million dollars a month from the
gambling
place yeah this rochester in his dreams
about 12 hours a day
only slots constantly so i mean sure it
could be legit
could not be dude there's you don't you
can
play for [ __ ] a billion hours you
don't just win 2.5 million dollars
period and
he's won over 1 million dollars at least
10 times i think
that's that's right that just doesn't
happen i'm sorry but people you don't
have they they make it look like you're
they're actually winning money
right does this guy like put it on like
i'm up on this game on playing slots
this random comment said that
he says he's down but is he down i think
he is actually
he's i don't know it's just a random
chatter so
but no so the same other one the ethics
of these guys
and unless they live in like one of the
few states like vegas
and new jersey that it's legal to play
they're breaking the law
the majority of people watching that
they're trying to sign up are breaking
the law
and by the way here's a cute little uh
thing for you
if the casino finds out you're
connecting from a non
an illegal state they'll keep all your
money nice
let's go so that's a nice little scheme
because you know these casinos
even if they are regulated they do
everything humanly possible to not pay
you
so if they find out you're connected
from whatever the [ __ ]
uh they're not going to pay you here's
this guy train wrecks who apparently is
one of the biggest guys doing this right
now he just won a million dollars the
other day
you know just like you do you walk
through the casinos people are winning
million dollar every day
happens all the time so six pins
[Music]
once again he's got the code
please
he did it he did it it's just he clicked
the button
so like does twitch who's watching
[Music]
and these guys are some of the most
popular stream it's super popular to
watch just watch people gamble
yes yes
yeah like okay so uh show me all the
regular people not influencers or
streamers that win million dollars
regularly
nobody wins in slot machines area where
are
you know the people that actually win
slot machines are ones that like put one
dollar in while cruising through the
casino once
because when you're an addict you will
always
lose over time the odds of numbers are
always against you
so a few of these guys like i think
train wrecks and
another one like he's moving to canada
another one's moving to mexico so that
they can legally do it
but they've already been breaking the
law this whole [ __ ] time right
but that's how crazy the money is that
people are moving to mexico
yeah while streamers are required to
disclose sponsored ads they do not
always note that they're being given
money
with to gamble so a lot of these guys
apparently are probably give being given
money to gamble with because
you're not gonna if you sit there for
like 12 hours
and you're doing a hundred dollars per
spin you're going to lose everything
and it's not going to be pretty
so this is really interesting i'm afraid
what's going to happen is that
um a lot more countries especially
specifically the eu
has really tight gambling laws and so if
they see what's going on on twitch of
this whole unregulated gambling
promotion and everything
they can ban citizens all of europe
from accessing twitch is what's already
going on in slovakia
yeah this is this is so
shady you guys this is so shady i just
feel like
once again it's just telling about
twitch like
they gotta get their [ __ ] together
interesting comment somebody
uh mick jazz in the chat said he gamble
uh the talking about the roche stein guy
he gambles on the money he gets from
affiliates essentially rush stein
gambles with the money his viewers lose
gambling
yeah essentially right exactly if
they're paying him
yeah but i still don't trust the outcome
of those spins because they got to make
it interesting
yeah i mean that's like winning 2.5
million on a spin that's like one in
like a billion chance you know
yeah i mean i'm sure he would just argue
well i do this 12 hours a day every day
i'm bound to win eventually but yeah
it's
that's probably more likely than this
guy
xqc apparently a lot of people like him
but he used to do the gambling too and
he claimed
that he says
he's okay here he goes people want to
catch me in a live surprise surprise i
didn't lie
total people that actually use the thing
from weeks said
[Music]
i'm not understand okay here he says
he says i made is he saying i made minus
300 000 or
300 000. i made 300 000 from the ad
plus 3 million he says he made three
million dollars playing slot machines
do you believe that's really not real
that somehow all these switch streamers
are winning millions of dollars and so
that's literally statistically
impossible
it's impossible the probability
where's all the rich viewers then the
probability of
three twitch streamers all hitting
million dollars jackpots and making
millions of dollars
is [ __ ] zero
he's showing that he has wagered 29
million dollars
that's crazy what the [ __ ]
yeah i don't know dude this [ __ ] is
super [ __ ]
makes me very uncomfy as they say
here's another leaked dm these guys keep
leaking their dms like they can't
they're so [ __ ]
as if they're not masterminds so the
same guy q
uh xqc and this other guy train wrecks
who won a million dollars
look at how fast this leaked dm took
place look how fast it is
ready that was it really that was it
yeah watch
oh it's back here more right here watch
oh my god and then of course the the
mastermind
um well caught it and he's talking about
gambling were you able to
transcribe this hey because it's so
blurry i can't read what's here
no we couldn't find another capture but
mean love lover looking for it
it said basically the dm show train
wrecks giving cue xqc advice on
potentially working with another
gambling site
train wrecks addis added that he needed
to play on full screen and can't show
he's on stake in any capacity he says
that's why i need to move to canada asap
train wrecks said not that interesting i
guess
just this whole thing like how is this i
feel like this should be a way
bigger scandal that they're allowing
this on twitch
then then all the every the sexual stuff
that everybody's always up in arms about
like
promoting gambling to children it to me
is is worse
it's rock bottom yeah like well it
always goes back
to misogyny people like hating on women
right it's like the hot tub the hot tub
streamer is like
yeah i mean i'm going to have a meltdown
about that but yeah but this is
everybody melts down you know literally
ripping kids off getting them addicted
to one of the worst devices known to man
it's just breaking the law they're
portraying
a scenario that would never happen this
will never happen
it's impossible you will not win so and
even if you did
there's a good chance you're not in the
legal gambling site and they are not
going to pay you out anyway so
get [ __ ] you know it's just
wrong on so many levels this one guy
asman gold is one of the few people who
actually hasn't taken
the gambling money so shout out to this
guy he's a good dude
yeah i like this guy tuition needs to
ban gambling streams full stop the
amount of [ __ ] and pitfalls is going
to create in the next six months we'll
[ __ ] the website in so many ways we
don't even realize yet
just looking at eu gambling laws anyone
can see this will not end well this is
the guy who is uh
making a shitload of money right rash
stein
so that's him epic dude epic bro can't
wait for the fbi to ask you
show up at your house what a luck he's
right but again you gotta point the
finger at
twitch for allowing it and not at the
guys who go along with it you know what
i point the finger to everyone these
people have a responsibility to their
fans and not to [ __ ] put them down
the path of
of being gambling yeah that too but
there's always going to be those little
lives that
don't have any morals interesting super
chat that just came in
uh i work for a betting site that has a
youtube channel and we're not even
allowed to link to the site at the end
of the videos or mention betting or
gambling in the videos will all be
demonetized yeah exactly
exactly because youtube [ __ ] knows
what they're doing i mean
this is insane they have a little
overlay on all their gambling videos it
says
use this code at this site for whatever
deposit bonus
well anyway we decided you know with all
the money
people are making on gambling
that we wanted in on the action as well
so uh well i don't know if you
are you have that ready okay so so here
we are
doing our own version of uh of gambling
here at the h3 podcast so
[Applause]
enjoy
[Applause]
[Music]
guys hold on one sec i'll be right back
uh just keep the game going guys i don't
keep the game up
damn don't worry baby's chill it's all
good we're playing playing crafts with
the kids dude we're trying to get some
lunch money out here dude you can't be
like
what the [ __ ] if hilo finds out about
this you're gonna be [ __ ] hold on
hold on hold on
just shoot once just shoot once
you'll feel it you'll feel it shoot it
once here take this
i don't wanna take this get it come on
shoot it once [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
come on i know you got 50 cents you
didn't buy milk today i've been watching
you little kid
get ready here we go here we go
you just lost all your [ __ ] buddy
kids
[Applause]
take it
[Music]
i think everybody just lost their money
all right well don't worry there's
always next round come on let's keep it
moving
all right come on no snake eyes snake
eyes
no snake eyes no snake guys oh
hey stop what is this no we're just
having a little fun
stop stop
you're gambling you're taking money from
kids what is this
i mean was just a little fun i mean
they're just yeah i mean they're kinder
they're just kids and we're playing dice
uh where's ben
dan i dan producer producer dan i don't
know how i thought you would be more
responsible
yeah i did i didn't want him to steal
all the finally fired i think he's
no she's talking about the dice itself
oh oh
i think this is it we gotta cut this
she does have a point they are like 12.
you you got me into this you
they are like 12. dan i feel like you
should have stepped in no yeah you're
gonna put this on me
i mean he always has bad ideas i gotta
that's true she's right you should have
stopped this when it happened
[ __ ] you dan this is your fault you
should have stopped it when you walked
out here
and all these kids are gonna complain
and guess who i'm gonna send the fbi
after
dan swordlove who lives at one two five
seven
all right so he's the one so
we agreed and i also have my sunglasses
back
ela you agree though it's dan's fault
right
i mean always yeah it stands for okay
always all right
you didn't tell me i look so good in a
wife beater you know
anyway so that that's basically our
version of gambling we set up a live
stream for the kids
around the world to participate as we
shoot dice in the alley
and i will say we cleaned up like
probably what like 100 bucks i mean
there's definitely gonna be a lot of
like yeah yeah we got something
there's definitely dozens of kids not
eating lunch because
we we got it so oh yeah
so i am not returning there's nothing
you can do to make me return that
all right
um how's frenemies merch stealing
um do you want to address this one thing
that uh some people took
i think the wrong way go ahead just one
donation i
go ahead i'll take it i'll take it the
diabetes joke was super distasteful
okay we can't afford insulin because the
government sucks
i know that's my job i'm type one and
have supported you since day one but
that hurt
okay nobody was making fun of diabetic
people
i don't know so i feel like i feel like
you can correct it because i know you're
into thank you for the donation
i know your intention is expensive so
you probably should have kept the money
but
the joke is that the government is so
[ __ ]
yeah that our medical system is so
[ __ ] that you can buy all the mountain
dew you want
but you can't afford it you can't afford
insulin you know everywhere else in the
world it's like affordable except in
america with peace and love i think you
you misunderstood the jokes yeah it's
not directed
at you directly i love the diabetics
it's funny you might be one i'm soon to
be one yeah exactly
i'm i'm a few i'm a few pizzas away from
joining you myself
you know what i mean i'm one of you
[Laughter]
we love the diabetics it's just about
like
the [ __ ] up side of america oh yeah
love the diabetics
which is you know that gives you so send
send send
an email we'll get you a shot we'll get
you of insulin
i'll buy you a shot of insulin i don't
know if you can just do that
um we'll find a way get some black
market insulin
a diet does the fact that people can't
afford medicine it's like
that that doesn't happen in other
countries well that's that's my point is
that
walmart makes billions of
excuse me walmart makes billions
of dollars and there's [ __ ] people
who can't afford insulin it's just
the disparity is insane okay peace and
love
love peace and love my uh
oh so i have two stories left so dude
the ace families and such [ __ ] bro it's
kind of amazing and you know
as much as i it seems like they are
in like actually such [ __ ] and i as much
as i feel bad for the kids because they
have two kids and you know it's a
stressful situation for everyone
i called it man those kids are not going
to see a dime
well there's not going to be a diet
yeah but you know the ace family this
guy has been scheming for so long
and now he's about to lose everything
which he deserves
but it just goes to show like he's got
so many views
he's got so much uh a legitimate money
if he wasn't such a greedy [ __ ] piece
of [ __ ]
he would be doing great in life
it's like it's just such a uh
such a tale such a cautionary tale
anyway their big ace family home that
they're always flexing is being
foreclosed on
it i don't know how to how were they
lose not how are they not
i just don't understand living way
beyond their means i guess
is just i felt i figured that they were
just
so wealthy from all this [ __ ] but i
think this boxing match really [ __ ]
here's their tour look how epic their
house store is ela
less than a year later they'd be getting
foreclosed on
so this is the charity that they
basically donated fifty thousand dollars
from and kept like millions
look at that
and so i don't know what what's
connected he's like well
here's where all the money went
wait we wanted
apparently what they did was
in woodland hills there's like a huge
mountaintop there apparently this is the
most
expensive house in woodland hills there
was two big houses on a hill
they bought them both and joined them
together they got a nine million dollar
this is all public record
they got a nine million dollar loan
and then another one million dollar loan
god what bank gave them a million
dollars in reality i mean nine guys
got scammed you know
and um the records show that they
haven't made a single payment on the
house
mortgage or property tax since the
beginning of
the year wow and so now the bank is
coming to foreclose on them
and he's he
deserves it i mean he does both of them
that is such a wild story
especially when it's like a family
channel
but they must be making so much money
like i mean the videos do great
it's family oriented the revenue must be
insane it's like the dude just
couldn't help himself so
you know you guys have heard about the
the big boxing match
that uh they did where none of the
fighters got paid because they didn't
sell enough
so here is first death noodles broke the
store i mean it was the first time i saw
it
here is the foreclosure details
uh notice of default
here's the house on zillow
pre-foreclosure and it's apparently it's
only listed at 7.5 million which is
funny because he took nine million
dollars out
no matter how you cut it even if he
sells it he's [ __ ] i saw people refer
to it as a 15 million dollar home so i
don't know
i don't know where they got that i don't
know yeah
i was saying we're 15 million
um they're also facing two lawsuits one
a construction company rental that
they've never paid
and uh another they're actually facing
three lawsuits
pre-foreclosure and not paying fighters
i mean this guy in the world of [ __ ]
it's kind of nice to be honest like to
just see one of these
absolute shit-tier scammers just getting
his comeuppance
i mean everybody he screwed over is
never going to get a dime but
here's a lawsuit ace family collection
ace hat collection
hats apparently ace hat collection also
owns the house that's foreclosing so i
think he just thinks if he goes bankrupt
he can uh just get rid of everything but
i need that clout
and then this thing also happened where
a car company was like yo we lent him
two exotic cars for the fight and he
never paid us he's been ghosting us
everyone is like saying everywhere how
they feel so bad for the kids and it's
just
it's so how could they be so
irresponsible especially when you're
making your kids
like part of the show you know
dude i swear to god they're just i i
hate to even paint a broad brush like
this but i think both of them are just
really shitty people
like genuinely shitty people what makes
you say that
because you know like if you were a good
parent
if you were a good parent and you
clickbaited your kids in all of your
videos you would put
you would put aside like a trust or
something and give a piece of the cash
to them
i guarantee you you'd be responsible
with your money to the point of not
being evicted from your own home
oh do you have the message he put out um
on his instagram story yeah so he put
out a statement recently
look at this he's like yeah this is from
his instagram he goes stop
capping on me and my family nobody's
getting evicted nobody's moving
stop believing everything you see haters
say on the internet
if we were moving we definitely would
have informed the world and make a whole
youtube video about it have a good rest
of your day well zack's brothers
the papers are real so yeah no there's
no question about it zack's brother has
he's like a realtor you want to tell the
story zach so i don't know oh yeah
he's not a realtor yet he's getting his
license he's almost going to get it but
um
you can there's a back end system for
people in real estate to see title and
what you own a house and
we verified that he did in fact default
yeah no it's all there
he checked the records i see at this
point there's a bunch of articles about
it everyone's verified
he's in default he's gonna lose this
house i don't even know why he's trying
to lie and be like yeah
stop capping on me bro i need that clout
the chat said austin paid off too many
side chicks that's why they don't have
ah
it could be what happened
yeah the rumor about him is that he's
perpetually cheating on his wife and i
don't think his wife actually cares
i think they just have like they need to
maintain this family image
yeah like a house of cards couple right
yeah
man yeah apparently his house is being
set to be sold at auction up for
uh pre foreclosure at september 22nd and
what would be kind of an epic flex for
me to buy their house elo
no you can make it the h3 clout house
i could get a jet ski and i could be the
one dumping water and all the neighbors
nah i'm bad vibes not by the ostomates
cursed house that house looks like such
a dump though didn't you
didn't you learn anything from uh
william that's bad energy that you're
gonna
inherit yeah you're right it's bad
energy here look um
look at this article it says it's a 15
million dollar
i don't know where they're getting that
from it says seven million
some people said that they bought a
third property i don't know if that's
possibly why i'm looking into that now
um i'm not curious it's more money than
it does yeah it doesn't really matter
yeah
it's no the house looks like a total
like one of these really low quality you
see these all the time in l.a
just really hastily shittily built like
there's problems with all the
and all of it you know what i mean yo is
cam making memes by the way
he is yeah we kept sending them to you
what the [ __ ] you gotta die i'm not
checking anything
i think someone should be in control of
um yeah i was gonna
tell them after the show here's the ace
family house tour of next year they're
in an alley i'm a star i might
really start selling the clout pill yeah
you might want to
you're definitely going to need income
wherever you can find it
cloud pill whatever it is yeah
well at least they set their
expectations in the right place
i'm hoping their kids have a more maybe
someone they can live with because
that's not good conditions for a kid
look how [ __ ] their lot is though like
look how depressing that is
they only show like this part right um
but like look how actually [ __ ] their
lot is
oh yeah disgusting
are you just kidding i mean yeah i
didn't hate to live there
okay sorry i'm just saying like they
only show this
but like it's all just a dirt lot right
in this really it's like a monster or
how much they paid
you're saying golly okay sorry maybe i'm
out of touch yeah
yeah sorry everybody
and i don't know you can make it up to
us by buying his house and turning that
into
the h3 cloud house we can all live there
together
i miss all these great memes i kept
pinging you
how the f i'm not looking at discord it
pops up on your screen somebody's got to
be in control this that's not me
okay we'll figure it out somebody's got
to put this on screen as i'm talking all
right
so this is the war of h3 podcast verse
impulsive
oh that's so late yeah i know but i i
feel like it's worth trying this cam
cameron you want to come say hi
cameron's our new uh
cast member yeah he's does editing he's
an ex
he's an extraordinary editor and uh
digital master he's been making memes
some of you guys may know him he's been
making me
we've been showing his memes on the
podcast for like a year now
because he's kind of a meme the meme
master yeah so he
he moved out here and he's working here
full-time he's part of the gang so say
hi cameron
hi cameron how you guys doing out there
thanks for hiring me i'm glad to be here
i'm very anxious
you're such a great voice cam oh thank
you very much oh wait is the camera that
way yeah
hi everybody out there in h3 land
yeah you used to work for adult swim so
you have a good background you have a
fantastic background right i mean
i hope so yeah yeah well he's been doing
a lot of the edits that everyone has
been loving so
cameron uh do you do you like uh david
dobrik i'm kidding don't answer that
baby don't be out here don't go there
baby
i'm not dealing with that [ __ ] today
he's already told us not to get canceled
right he's actually an ace family fan oh
yeah a big stand of them
yeah cameron did you make this one or
was this just from the internet
uh which one another internet but i can
make more in that uh
variation on that theme
[Laughter]
um the other one is here i'm gonna show
all your memes that you made today okay
cool
yeah i think the optimal ways if
somebody could just slide it on the
screen and then surprise me with it
all right that would be fun all right
this is another zac meme this is
fantastic here we go
zach uh recording after accident zach
recording after dark
that's just mean cam that's actually
that's so true that is true
you have to own that all right i don't
know but i was frazzled in that
situation
i just glanced at the chat the chat is
demanding the cam stand up
get up cam stand up cam
every time yeah so the h3 podcast grows
and um
we got just the best team the greatest
people we're so happy to have cameron
here
and uh we love you oh we have a walmart
meme here we love you
oh i love you too we're in love with you
well we love you i mean it's a
colloquial thing here
this is what we got here they're
watching after dark at walmart oh my god
oh yeah
[Laughter]
don't let them watch let them see what
we're saying about them yeah i've yeah
right from the self checkout i just
gotta say it's been great having cam
in the office and uh he's such a
positive vibe and
yeah he says that and then you become
the new heartthrob and then he [ __ ]
hates you and then passes
i'm trying to compliment him he'll be
your best friend for a few months but
i'm trying to say anything about you
enjoy chill i just
i just want to say that it's been great
out of camp jesus don't take my nuts
away if you guys want to know what a
talent cameron is
um he's been making this kind of [ __ ]
he just whips these up you know
[Music]
so this is you know expect more this is
something we're going to be working on
next week is the whole series
uh with the whole gang and everything so
a lot going on here
now eb's hugging me
it's too late av
all right thank you very much well
cameron i don't know if you want to
comment on this next story
did you know that um boy scouts of
america
is agreed to a settlement for 850
million dollars
for more listen to this over
84 000 people claim they were
essayed by the scouts 84
000 dude what
thoughts cameron yeah uh a photoshop
comes to mind and i'll get right to it
all right i can't wait to see it all
right talk to you soon
oh my god really 84 000
and those are people who just came
forward for this lawsuit
uh they're totally bankrupt that's
almost a billion dollars that their
boy scouts of america were having to pay
victims of essay
and uh wow they're just they've gone
into bankruptcy
but that that is unbelievable i mean
that's just that's basically at that
point what they do
that's who they are that's
so we're the boy scouts and this is what
we do and who we are
this is a little spooky goat
that's horrific yeah anyway that's it
anything in the chat that wants us to
get to um
dan you have anything saved i've got a
whole list in here let's see what we got
just for like um
there was a 100 donation ela
would you ever consider doing a teddy
fresh toddler slash kids clothing my son
is the same age as theodore
nuts for it much love to you guys in the
crew from michigan
yeah i have been considering it there's
one
that's going to be coming out this year
um a color black hoodie for kids
and uh that's gonna be the first one so
sick and we'll see how it does
but yeah i would love to do more
do the color block kit hoodie for kids
is so sick
yeah yeah do you have a link to the um
mom and dad and apple pie video
[Music]
the mom and dad that's a miracle the
song
i can't find the original i can only
find the one i made babies on it
um let's see what else we got here there
was another in the discord
no i think zach was jack was playing i
think he just has the
whole thing on his soundboard uh
another hundred dollar donation sir look
at what you did to my car
h3h3 is that great thank you
yep thank you i tried to do it in mo
billy mary's voice because it's real
[ __ ] funny sir you hit my car
is it tyrone davis the apple pie guy
i don't know what the [ __ ] do i know i
don't even know the song i don't know
what i'm like
either oh my god you found it i don't
know i don't know what i'm looking for
i don't know this mom's apple pie well
did you click it
i mean just but i don't i don't but what
am i looking now okay
that's not it what the [ __ ] did you send
me play it dan
that's not it well i don't know the song
so i don't know what i'm looking for
it's from the one we were playing
earlier yeah right mom
and dad memorize it do you just want me
to play this song
and christmas in july that's
america that's america
um baby update i don't have many updates
it's just been
steady you want to show your tummy
there's a
i feel like you don't really see it yet
unless it's like i'm not using me like
naked but
which i do
she looks good wow dude you wouldn't
notice i
i know because i i show it to people
around me at teddy fresh and they're
like
you don't look any different i'm like no
i don't fit in my clothes
but can i say something um you know what
i'm gonna say
i don't know can i say it dude her boobs
are [ __ ] cute i had a feeling that's
how did i know i don't know you knew
because he said it previously
the first time she's no but this time
it's even crazier whoa even crazier huh
she's like embarrassed to show me
because she knows i'm gonna be like oh
[ __ ] look at those milkers mommy
oh gross stop that's enough
um somebody just donate a hundred
dollars uh
oh my god ethan and h3 crew thank you
for inspiring us to start a podcast oh
stop
oh start a podcast those introverts all
right we'll shout out hello
shout outs to the introverts the
introverts
um somebody just donated five dollars to
beanie sold out congrats friends oh my
god
goodness okay people do want this oh
[ __ ] me in the tits
somebody else somebody else just said uh
five dollars in the tent
i'm a foreigner sorry excuse me i know i
know i'm sorry that was so vulgar
i just think she looks
donated five ducks said i'm a former boy
scout and it's honestly disgusting what
it's become
unfortunately i have multiple stories
about the stuff you're alluding to oh
wow
sorry to hear that i think it was
happening it was happening
every day in one tent because they go on
like camping or retreats i saw like a
documentary about where they go camping
and there's camp
counselors and tents it's happening
every night in one of those tents
crazy i would i did boy scouts for not
for a super long time
but i was like a cub scout for maybe two
years in a boy scout for a year so i
think i did it for about three years
total they never got to you
they they didn't get to me uh i i
managed to
escape goodness unharmed but um the one
that got away
right that's wrong well i'm glad i'm
glad because you know the people that
that does happen to it it really [ __ ]
ruins course
awful i mean the damages that that does
to a young child
is just uh you're immeasurable it's just
horrific [ __ ] up
uh somebody just donated 10 bucks said
cosplay as
fangoolie that was the character your
mom
brought up or i guess you brought it up
you know i have a few more stuff to
watch actually i just realized there was
a bunch of stuff at the top of the show
i said someone
someone donated in sheco hey shout out
to you
i hope you have a good time visit 15
that's what like like four bucks
um about sounds about right
here okay this girl made an after dark
parody
that was so good it honestly hurt my
feelings
it's so freaking accurate oh no i'm not
writing it's so freaking accurate
the thing is like she obviously watches
every episode because she gets every
meme right this her name is uh
miserable
like miserable miserable miserable
anyway this [ __ ] is like way too good
bro but i'm going to play it in shame
worst nightmare right i have never
talked about triller on this podcast
look at abs and please that's me dude
ian please stand up
that way i mean i mean i mean love yeah
yeah the love's face here and please
stand up
ian please stand up ian please stand up
ian please stand up she got all the
clean sound bites still hey baby
we've got white club waiting
[Laughter]
unable to be heard she's kind of taking
shots at you zach with the sound bites
too like
she got all the clean sound bites and
she's playing them just as good
yeah yeah it's a good video
didn't hurt your feelings no i mean it's
a little overkill but
you're kind of doing that calm voice you
were doing in the car accident
well you want me to get mad at you dan
we have another special guest
and we have gillane maxwell everybody on
the phone
right now elaine are you there so how
does it does it all
is my hair good yeah so
elaine how do you well don't be stupid
feel about the allegations
that you groomed young girls for your
friend jeffrey
by 2050 will be depleted of major fish
stocks
so what you're saying is that you think
girls
are like fish if the ocean dies i'm not
sure
exactly what the outcome will be you're
saying the ocean is like
epstein so wouldn't you say the oh this
girl is [ __ ]
so funny and so good
it's insane she's not over 18 though
right because i'm ready to hire her but
that's what the chat is saying
yeah they're saying hire her well i'm
ready to but i don't know what's her
employment status or age but she's one
funny talented mother
i mean god damn crazy ocean
is already dead colleen tell everybody
how much you love the ocean
listen delane this has been very
unhelpful
you're on the wrong street because
that's just all the clean sounds
can we get that as a sound bite
her instagram says she is 24. oh my
goodness she's like
an adult he's older than me [ __ ] young i
guess older than me too
so i think we gotta get in contact with
this yeah
if she i can't tell if she
i don't know she might be she might be
like too talented for us
she's way beyond us good luck ethan oh
uh today's episode is sponsored by me
undies
get your underwear delivered undies
delivered
to your door with
shut up [ __ ]
love how do you feel about that she's
doing it so good every time he shows
love on there i'm just like wow
well yeah she's really good i won't uh i
won't deny that
but she doesn't have to like actually
try i don't have to try
right oh yeah love you don't try
anything
no exactly use code h3
you can use the money you're not that
you're saving
[ __ ] i'm laughing too much
epstein's island money come on that was
that was fun
that was fun it's funny oh it turns out
that if you use
the five percent he takes that five
degrees
could have written you a better joke
than that
that one hurt ian started interrupting
she does have all the clean ones [ __ ]
i know she got all the clean sounds it's
impressive a lot of time into this
it's not easy to find like the exact
video the exact spot
i just that just kind of reminded me of
when i basically i
just had had a lot of sex so she kind of
[ __ ] went after you a lot
is that me that's you
could have written you a better joke
than that
that one hurt ian sorry to interrupt
this is that uab
kind of reminded me of when i basically
uh just had had a lot of sex so
nice baby
that was pretty good yeah i wasn't
thinking i was thinking all the times i
had sex i wasn't paying attention
are we is it a possibility to get her to
call in
i'd love to let's start there i don't
know who she is uh but
well i do know her who she is she's
miserable
actually i know who the [ __ ] she is you
got she's got uh instagram
link right here
i'm so glad she listed her age because i
would have never even reached out well
we're going to reach out to her dan
make contact she's a genius okay
someone in the chat just donated five
dollars he takes that five percent
you're a piece of garbage i wish you
would just shut up
well you're fat ela was this a bad
episode yeah i thought it was pretty
funny
thank you everyone for tuning in peace
and love
peace and love warning you with peace
and love see you next time
what do you want to get for now i don't
want anything dude come on no
let's go right now what do you want to
do i don't
that was insane i feel like uh i don't
like being uh
uh analyzed that deeply it makes me feel
like i'm a hack
she made me feel like a hat but she's
clearly watched every episode
right come on right
uh there's a few more things i want to
look at chat says she's
here oh she's in the chat i don't know i
haven't seen it but
miserable if you're in the chat if you
remember call in let's do a call right
now i'll give a [ __ ]
message zach or any of these guys on on
uh
well maybe one of you guys can connect
on like instagram or something else
that's quicker
because i don't know i have her
instagram open if she wants to message
me
message a b or the podcast thank you
peace and love thank you thank you
here is keem you know keemstar is the
biggest piece of [ __ ] in the world right
well here he is getting absolutely
manhandled by this [ __ ] weirdo
this is like back in the day i guess i
don't know what's the context
but this guy just [ __ ] out keemstar
he makes him a little cocky
and uh keemstar just it's great
this is i don't know who this guy is but
he's the only one that's ever cocked
keemstar like that he's third keep
starting to a low soybean he's like a
greek billionaire or something and he
ran
a gaming streaming thing about a decade
ago
what shut up [ __ ] that's so weird
yeah it was like a whole thing it's too
much to get into but
well at any rate he shut the keemstar
the [ __ ] up and i've never seen anyone
do that so
keemstar shut up it's pretty amazing
he's really scared of him or something
[Laughter]
this is such a weird clip the only
person
exactly like who talks like that and
it's keemstar
and it's all just so good it's live
shut up [ __ ]
fantastic i wanted to show you guys this
as we're trying to get a hold with ms
rebella
i made this tweet today you guys can go
on my twitter account and find it
if you want i mean it's on twitter
that's my only point
uh right here every time i think of ryan
kavanagh
i think of his business partner alleging
he was involved in a ponzi scheme
i retweeted it myself oh i never do that
but i thought it was such a good tweet i
even liked and retweeted my own tweet
wow oh and then the podcast said not to
mention that kevin hart isn't even on
trailer
yeah so if you like this tweet retweet
it like it you know
that's what you do on twitter right you
see how wendy williams trending look at
this she's been canceled like
she's trending with 30 000 tweets that's
pretty serious
when wendy williams comes under fire for
segment of on this tick tock star's
death that was the weirdest thing ever
oh it was it was brutal it was so
inappropriate
what was the point of like comparing sub
cones and all that stuff it's just
right the dude is dead it's not you know
oh speaking of which wendy william open
opens her mouth social media
yeah no such thing as a
he's got more coincidence than me 2.5
million
is this just this girl watching oh we
got oh we got a whole [ __ ]
monologue let's go let's see what she
has to say about it
imagine living in a world where before
you announce to your audience that
somebody has died you make fun of their
appearance
then at your huge ass age you compare
follower count
then in the middle of announcing that
somebody has been murdered
you forgot who died then after telling
the story about how a 19 year old no
longer has this life
you say all those followers not my
condolences to the friends family and
followers who will no longer
enjoy swabi nor his content but
all those followers i've been on social
media since my space and i learned a lot
the most important thing i've learned is
i don't like some people and that's okay
wendy you are on a downward spiral this
is why when i'm going
die die time
yeah it's time it's so crazy for her to
be like um
i don't know anything about this guy
he's he looks funny
he i don't know why he's famous he
shouldn't be famous and also he's dead
oh this is wendy williams leg apparently
or her body
interesting observation hot dog shaped
body
my mother she's like wendy you've got
them they're long you show them
all right crap if you think she should
tougher she also talked me into picking
out this outfit today
she's also died
bro my brother bro did you have you've
got this [ __ ] this is her announcing her
mom died
girl you got to work on your death
enough yeah
whenever it comes to death she really
fumbles the ball
my mother she's like wendy you've got
them they're long you show them
if you ever pass away early which god
forbid
i mean i don't like to think about that
but if you did i would be like
ela
she uh she had just over 1 million
followers on
instagram less followers than me
no presidents on tick tock though
horrible tick tock presidents could
never get around
you know uh
never cooked for me all right
i'll make a great salad for you that's
true
anyway she's dead anyway moving on
yeah right i would quit i think if you
died i would just quit i would disappear
for like a long time crawl into a hole
so don't die please thank you piece of
love um
okay jeff whittak
the podcast this guy's out of his mind
bro jeff whitaker is out of his [ __ ]
mind
look at this guy he's trying to act like
such a tough guy jeff whitakes the guy
who saw trisha in starbucks and [ __ ]
left his food he paid for on the counter
and he's trying to act like a tough guy
oh you got a mim on screen
oh so can they see that i just figured
out a way to do it
oh yes hi scouters show that
they can't see it oh okay
hi scouter that is a boys and
uh club uh
boy scouts name
hi scouters james charles would make a
good counselor wouldn't he
everybody's saying watch her frenemies
video
of the same girl but oh she ha
i haven't seen those ones but i think
she made but yeah just go check out her
channel i'm sure she's insane yeah
talented yeah anyway listen to jeff
woodick
who's trying to act tough here i'm
assuming he's talking about me and
trisha
the podcast right now with those rats
that [ __ ] inspired this
this is my merch rad exterminator
company would it it's not a real one but
when i say exterminate i'm gonna [ __ ]
jeff you are such a giant [ __ ] you have
not exterminated anything but your own
[ __ ] career
and by the way by the way you are such a
coward you don't you won't do
[ __ ] your exterminator like i said you
ran away from trisha and starbucks
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] dude
shut up stop trying to act tough dude
you're not exterminating [ __ ] who are
you exterminating
the one guy that actually wronged you
you went running back to him like a
puppy dog because you needed the clout
you [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm sorry but like
this is a [ __ ] this is
this is look at this this pissed me off
this is my merch
i'm a rat exterminator who's a rat not a
real one but when i say exterminate i'm
gonna [ __ ]
who's a rat bro you're in a [ __ ]
rat's nest right now shut the [ __ ] up
too harsh okay ethan
okay i don't know i thought this was
like so tasteless
it's like one thing to like joust but to
be like
you're i'm a [ __ ] rat exterminator
and i'm gonna exterminate the rats
i mean he hasn't shown taste since
everything that i've seen from him so
you know especially come from the guy
who ditched his own food in starbucks
because he saw trisha like
uh yeah sounds like a real rat
exterminator to me
[ __ ] you
it pissed me off i don't know maybe i'm
maybe i'm taking it too personally
yeah i don't know he's just kind of like
kind of full of himself yeah it's nice
it's more funny i don't know
i just don't like the tough guy bravado
i hate all these [ __ ]
much of my joke i don't know why it
pissed me off maybe i'm just
you know too much the the problem with
jeff is like i like him on a personal
level when we talk and stuff like that i
get the appeal
why i don't know but like
literally why what what is this
appealing to i think he's
funny and nice and uh seems like a loyal
friend to
david even though he tried i mean you
don't know him being a loyal friend
no i'm saying that's i'm conflicted i
don't i just don't know him i don't get
what the positive qualities are
everything that i've seen from him he
seems like a douche
mega douche you know what you're a rat
and you're about the exterminated
but if i see you in a starbucks i'm
gonna leave my food in jet remember when
he sicked all of his fan base on a
reporter because she reported on
something he didn't like and then he
didn't read the article and then came on
the air to argue with you about it it's
just like
you that's what he did the [ __ ] idiot
that's what he [ __ ] exterminating the
rap absolute
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah i don't i don't i
don't see what the redemptive quality is
i just want to note that i think he let
ignored tricia at starbucks i don't
think it was that he left his food but
no that wasn't the story he left and he
left the food yeah the story is he left
his order on the counter because he was
in such speed to get away from her i'm
direct exterminator
if i see a rat i'm gonna run
also that's western exterminator's logo
uh they probably
would not appreciate him stealing their
logo for his merch
yeah it's a famous logo oh
here i'll show you oh it's this it's a
total ripoff
oh show me show me something cam can you
do it side by side
yes i'll just send you the link he just
ripped off the image yeah that's no good
unless was he just joking and that's not
his merch i don't know
but maybe i'm overreacting
sorry jeff don't kill me
he ain't going [ __ ] here
oh this is the literal same [ __ ]
same everything so was it just this
shirt maybe it was just a gag
i i don't know okay
we are unaware of the i know if it's
real merch or not yeah
but regardless and then finally we have
rice gum
uh who's getting absolutely roasted by
an old man
on his live stream who said who's
telling him to keep it down
oh yeah what he's i don't know why rice
has been doing the irl streams where he
just like posts up at a starbucks
okay anyway he's pissing off the people
around him and he gets [ __ ] on it's
awesome
all day stop yelling bro what are you
all set
what what what what
you love that four-letter word what word
the one that they're recording
they're recording me you bet you can
hear you all the way down
i don't know you know what exactly
you do but that has a microphone
[Laughter]
okay he's like
this guy's roasting the [ __ ] you're
gonna get nowhere i can tell you that
okay okay damn man you're in an area
good response ricegum
oh thank you sir nah sarah i love how he
goes so thank you sir
tough guy rice thank you sir thank you
i am loud and i am saying some words and
i apologize you know
i say some words he's like no i'm not a
successful broadcaster i just steal
money from my fans it's all good
yeah yeah
he thinks it's funny but this guy's
actually ruining him yeah
that's true no but but i can't really
hear him at this point
i don't care
yeah anyway i'm sorry sir i'm so
sorry it's kind of like jeff wedding
vibes this is what jeff sees when uh
no look look oh no another meme
so i am the rat yeah that's what jeff
sees when he sees me
please don't come exterminate me even
though i think you're a giant [ __ ] and
wouldn't actually do [ __ ]
but don't test that theory i'm i am a
giant i'll tell you right now
i'm a giant [ __ ]
a huge [ __ ] don't step to me please
oh you guys want to show this uh zach
had a big show in santa barbara the
whole gang went
zach's live music career picking up
so this is the girl you performed with
zach yes
this is probably copyrighted if you're
doing covers
uh at the first part of this video i
don't we're not like
he did a really good job so after we
wrapped up our episode on wednesday oh
wow i didn't realize i got a whole
[ __ ] produced thing from you you got
the ab
goat okay voice over and everything
i didn't know how to do it okay here we
go brought to you by a.b
invited us to go watch and perform at
some live show that was like two hours
away
and ethan said it'd be cool if one of us
went to record some footage for the show
so i said why not unfortunately my other
co-workers weren't too enthusiastic
about going
no all right gang you guys are sure
you all don't want to go and we'll be
there
sam's going to be there ian you going
ian wasn't sure don't go talk to me nice
dick dug me man
just because of the four hour drive
being that it was a work night it's not
four hours well i guess both ways
no traffic going there man it's a
two-hour drive i was like zach you're
doing a show
um that's awesome where is it i was like
hollywood i'll go
he's like santa barbara i was like [ __ ]
you i'm not going to
love you though that's a little bad
because sam wanted to go and
i kind of betrayed ian by taking her
side in the situation
dan no i said over and over again i am
not going
uh peace and love to zach but i will not
be there
dan on the other hand was a solid no i
am not
going to drive four hours on a workday
thanks
dan so me and my wife felina headed out
our journey started with me paying a
[ __ ] ton for guests but on a brighter
note sam texted us on the way there and
said that she convinced ian to come
ian didn't look too happy about it i
felt kind of bad when i saw this photo
because
i really betrayed this guy
did you guys get recognized down there
tell you guys it's an awkward feeling
yeah
we did celebs zach calls us d-list i
think we're more like z-list but yeah we
got recognized
how many people recognize you guys there
was like several people handful yeah
wow that's not d-list that's pretty good
yeah this maybe
well if i'm a seedless celebrity then
yeah i don't know why are we talking
youtube terms or
one that you know is probably talking
[ __ ] about you the whole way there
you got a few drinks going too many okay
i'm gonna stop talking let's listen to
zach
my opinion one of the greatest songs
ever written so it's another word
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah i can't play this
you just played the band though yeah for
like five seconds that's what i gave you
too
i can't listen to you playing you didn't
d5
anyways that crushed it did they pay you
zach
no i just wanted to go up there and jump
in you get any tips
no i just i just wanted to first gig
back
complimentary drinks no you had to pay
for the [ __ ] drink free parking
no oh i didn't i just wanted to go and
play some music
wait did you pay to play no i would
never i would never pay to play with
that
okay singing yeah i think i found
something here
ccw
[Music]
clarence kleinwater what did you just
say bbw
[Applause]
yeah do you appreciate abe coming to
your show i appreciate everyone coming
out it was really nice even though yes
you play cc dubs
i honestly didn't hear that when i was
on stage i i only heard that uh when he
showed me the clip but yeah it was a
really good time and i appreciate
everyone coming and
you guys will have to make to the next
one because it'll be closer
absolutely i'll be there i told you from
the get-go
you play in l.a i'm there yeah we might
even [ __ ] you know all the way out
there if we like tweet it out and turn
into a whole people be like this zack
guy's on fire everywhere he goes a huge
[ __ ] crowd
three drinks you know we always mess
around on the show but i forget like how
talented zack actually is he really is
like a really good musician
oh yeah thank you i appreciate it
professional yeah
it was it was a really fun time i'm
happy for you thank you
yeah thank you nice of all you guys to
go out there too to be honest yeah oh we
got the mission
she is in the chat oh she's in the chat
yeah
uh let me go because i'm about to pee my
pants
also the rat tea in jeff's vids has
nothing to do with ue10 it is about
matt king a member of vlog squad oh
is it just an inside joke i guess so oh
i'm sorry uh i'm sorry
um why did you well because what did he
call it was about you
well who else would it be in a tweet
so yeah he called trisha rat recently on
twitter oh
okay i guess so at least they're not i
don't know i feel like we'd both be rats
in his mind i thought you had reason to
believe it was
no i have no reason well
no okay apologies to jeff
i don't apologize he's a [ __ ] another
person
right um another person said the curse
is real by the way i listened to the
cursed
band's music and someone rear-ended
and likely totaled my car two hours
later
yeah oh cece dubs there you go man
[ __ ] you that doesn't what is that where
is the w coming from he didn't want to
say the
clearance clean water just please i
don't know where i got ccw from
what do you mean the w is right there
clearance
plain water that's not their name well
you know what i'm saying no but even
then that's not
it's let him say it always says it there
it's ccr ccr
oh didn't say he wrote ccw that's what
i'm saying i said it wrong and sam was
like would you say ccw and
oh ian's like you said bbw a b was being
a good person and not saying the whole
acronym
he tried you're rubbing off on me ethan
all right well anyway
if there's nothing else that's about it
eh
this is evil's last show so is there
anything you want to say i mean we'll be
back in like probably three weeks
with after dark we'll be here uh the
guys will be here you know we'll be
doing our thing
but eel is there any parting words you
want to say um
no in just three weeks thank you
everyone have a good weekend
friday baby friday baby
[Music]
oh [ __ ] yeah
thank you to everyone that did buy
frenemy's merch
shettyfresh.com friends how'd it sell
get let's get an update
the beanie sold out no too i don't know
if we said that
but i think i mentioned it okay from a
chat yeah
okay [ __ ] split tea is sold out long
sleeve
and beanie that's [ __ ] good show me
the
shopify what are the numbers um
i don't know that we need to look at it
no
fair enough all right don't be shy come
on
all right either just want to open it
what do you want from me all right
well that's awesome the friendly [ __ ] is
doing great i mean i thought it wasn't
going to sell so i guess i owe you guys
lunch or something
you guys want to buy lunch what's for
lunch
it's about time to ask you i'd say
whatever elo wants cows
i got a salad already i brought a salad
too oh
solid days zach has the biggest [ __ ]
salad bowl i've ever seen
i'm on a diet i'm trying to create a
bowl of powder from a family of six
whatever that's a big bowl it's a puppy
he's eating salad baby why are you
getting
good i mean yeah he said he's losing
weight you're good i'm tired of eating
like [ __ ] so i bring a salad
brother hell yeah brother god bless get
inspired everyone
all right i'm gonna go eat my salad i'm
gonna go praise the friday
gods i'm gonna go shoot some dice for
kindergartners
and uh fantastic friday so thank you
everybody for watching as always
ela we wish you only the best possible
time on vacation thank you on your trip
good luck and saves travels and lots of
love
we will miss you dearly in the interim
we will miss
you dearly thank you
i will definitely and those
big juicy all right guys all right
thanks for watching thanks for watching
new fingernails all right all right
we're gone love those
bye-bye
[Music]
shredder will stop off him off readers
at the suite we'll do the real raw
ritual with more
and e.t share a laugh with the ringer
see how low jimmy lee
they said we wouldn't come back but you
we always do embrace from the ashes like
the phoenix on the flex back to two